[Music]
then you going to Ray's party yeah I'm
gone you know Amy's gonna be there ya
know things have been real good with her
man tonight could be the night could be
dude you okay
I don't really dude
what's fly yet the hottest girl at a
party with no parents you're definitely
gonna hit that for sure tonight man if
you lose that be for good my penis is
white excuse me I have a white penis
what but you're black no uh I'm biracial
all the way went straight to my penis
but what wait you mean like like the
color yeah but wait dude how bad could
it be but how bad it's like a Snickers
regular or fun sighs which one do you
get at Halloween
fine sighs that's the one I know what am
I gonna do I mean how am I gonna hit it
and Amy when little white penis
everyone's gonna find out no never gonna
hear the end of it due to Amy's white
she's not gonna care yeah she's white
yeah just right she's probably not even
gonna know difference
white girl white penis they're all good
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there is how'd it go last night
don't want to talk about it what
happened
black would join
you